the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
as you all know i am in the middle of
writing my own version of game of
thrones season 9.
i'm making these videos because i wanted
to show what could happen with these
characters if hbo decided to make more
episodes
in this season i am hoping i can give
some of the characters better endings as
well as answer some of game of thrones
biggest mysteries
now i'm not exactly sure how many
episodes i will make but since i am
nearing the end of this story
i will have to begin answering some of
these mysteries very soon
since there are so many big mysteries
still left i want to have answers for
them before the end
so you will eventually start to notice i
am laying out some of the information
thick because i want to reveal certain
things by the final episode
some of the nuances and subtleties will
go away as this season comes to an end
it's not like the early seasons of the
show when we still had
dozens and dozens of episodes to slowly
lay all this information out
i don't want to end my season the same
way dan and dave did theirs
by leaving so many things unanswered
hopefully you will keep all of that in
mind
as we move forward now let's jump into
my next episode
this is game of thrones season 9 episode
3 which i am naming
the one true king shall we begin
like the first episode of this season
this one will start off by showing us a
cold opening
that means we will be thrown into a
scene before the opening credits even
begin
the very first scene of this episode is
another series of flashbacks
the first thing we see is a glimpse of
the night king's creation
as leif inserts the dragonglass dagger
into the man's chest
then we're back inside the thread
raven's cave this was when bran realized
the night king was made by the children
of the forest
we will once again hear why they did
this leaf says they were at war
they were being slaughtered and their
sacred weirwood trees were being cut
down
now this is usually when the scene ends
but now we get to hear what else was
said during the flashback
after elise said why they created the
night king the three-eyed raven then
says fearing extinction the children
combined their powers for one
last spell that would save their people
and their land from the invaders by
themselves the
children were too few to resist the
onslaught
but if they could turn men's numbers
against
them now we flash to something else
we see the night king standing in what
looks like a crypt
while holding a newborn baby boy the
night king is then seen handing this
baby to a child of the forest
this child of the forest is one we have
never seen before
we watch it as it walks away from the
night king now holding the baby
until they fade away into the darkness
now we flash to something else
we hear the mad king say burn them all
as we see daenerys burning down king's
landing
then we see brian stark the moment he
becomes the new king of westeros
we hear him say why do you think i came
all this way
let me wear the crown
why do you think i came all this way
[Music]
now we flash to something else we see a
man who looks sort of like the same man
who became the night king
only this man is standing in front of a
castle as it's being built
gathered around this man is a few
members of the children of the forest
ones we have never seen before it looks
like they are helping this man build the
castle
now we flash back to the three-eyed
ravens cave we see bran sitting there
as the three-odd raven goes into more
details about the first men of westeros
the children of the forest
and why they made the night king after
hundreds of years and
untold death and destruction the wisest
heads of the children
and the first men finally prevailed
the children couldn't win this war and
the first men didn't want
to win fearing the costs of victory
heroes and rulers on both sides met
upon an aisle in the gods eye to form
the pact
now we flash to something else we see a
massive werewolf
surrounded by what looks like a grove of
more werewolves
all facing inward the massive werewolf
in the center has an enormous
face carved into it the face on this
werewood is so enormous
we actually see its mouth open and when
that happens
a child of the forest walks out of it
this unknown child of the forest
is holding a newborn baby that has
bright blue eyes
now we flash to something else we see
arya stark
as she is standing in front of jack and
nagar we hear arya
now we flash to something else we see a
few men with very long beards
standing in the forest they are chopping
down a giant werewolf
then throwing its branches into a fire
as the werewood burns in the fire
the crackling in the flames sounds like
the screams of a thousand children dying
when the smoke rises up from the fire we
see it form the shape of what looks like
the face on a werewood
but none of the men standing there
seemed to notice it now we flash to
something else
we see the mass of werewood again
surrounded by what looks like a grove of
more werewolves
all facing inward there are seven
members of the children of the forest
all standing in a circle around the
giant werewolf
they're all watching as one of their
elders who has long white hair
with a very long white beard walk
forward he stops when he is standing in
front of another child of the forest
who is kneeling in front of the weirwood
we see this elder behead the kneeling
child of the forest
the lifeless body falls to the ground
but the elder is still holding the head
by its hair
we see the enormous mouth on the
werewood open up
the elder member of the children throws
the head inside the mouth
right before it shuts now we flash back
to the three-eyed raven's cave
we see bran sitting there as the
three-eyed raven goes into
more details about the first men of
westeros the children of the forest
and why they made the night king the
children gave up
all the lands of westeros save for the
deep forests
and the first men swore that they would
no longer cut down the weirwoods
thus ended the dawn age and began
the age of heroes
yet after the dawn must come the night
the great evil that the children
unleashed in the war
returned centuries later now we flash to
something else
we see the massive wherewit again
surrounded by what looks like a grove of
more werewolves
all facing inward only now we see what
looks like the shadow of a dragon flying
over the werewoods
now we flash back through the three at
ravens cave we see brain stark sitting
there
as the three-eyed raven goes into more
details about the first men of westeros
the children of the forest and why they
made the night king
the great evil that the children
unleashed in the war
returned centuries later and only an
alliance between the children and men
defeated it now it comes again
when the children are a shadow of what
they were
and men have long forgotten
but the trees remember and brandon stark
must learn or as we watched
the first men so we will watch the last
[Music]
everything now fades to black bran stark
snaps out of his visions
gasping for breath he looks over his
shoulder at the door
worried someone might have walked in
while he was gone
there's no one there as he slows down
his heavy breathing
he looks down and notices both of his
hands have a firm grip on his chair
these are the most intense visions he's
ever had
bran finally begins to gain his
composure as he gazes into the fire in
front of him
we can see there is a note laying across
bran's lap
most likely something he was reading
before he went into the visions
as bran lifts it back up we get a
glimpse of it
we can see it has the broken seal of
house stark
we're not able to make out what it says
but we do see there are some rough
sketches of a few different
images one of the drawings shows what
looks like a beheading
as well as a very large werewolf
surrounded by other werewoods
before we can see anything else bran
crumbles up the note in his fist
then throws it in the fire now we see
the opening credits
and the theme song
like with all of my flashback scenes
they foreshadow some of the major events
that will happen
in future episodes the flashbacks have
answers to some of game of thrones
greatest mysteries
which will be revealed by the end of my
season so
i hope all of you are digesting all of
this information
after the opening credits are over we go
to our next scene in the episode
we're back across the narrow sea in
volantis
there are still thousands and thousands
of people gathered below
in the city streets the red temple of
verlor sits high on its hill looming
above all those who worship its lord of
light
kinvara as well as the other
high-ranking members of velour
are dressed in their red robes standing
in front of the massive doors to the
main entrance
all of their eyes are locked on daenerys
targaryen as she steps out of the
enormous brazier
the bottom of her feet are now blackened
with ash
grey and black smoke can be seen rolling
out of the large stab wound on her chest
daenerys looks up at drogon who is still
sitting atop the red temple of her lore
when drogon looks into her now opened
eyes he lets out a scream that can only
be described as a cry of ecstasy
in anguish the sound of her dragon makes
daenerys fall to her knees
kinvara rushes over and throws her red
robe around daenerys's naked body
kinvara slowly helps her back on her
feet she says
walk with me daenerys stormborn we
should speak inside
four men who are also wearing the red
robes
open the massive doors that have the
burning hearts engraved on the front of
them
the red temple of verlor opens up to a
great hall of its own
there are over 100 different braziers
burning inside lining all four of the
walls
there is also a very large burning heart
hanging down from the ceiling
in the center of the great hall kinvara
helps daenerys sit down on a stone bench
inside
what do you remember daenerys stormborn
do you know where you are
do you remember what happened daenerys
glances around the great hall
but nothing stands out to her none of
this looks familiar
she then looks down at the large stab
wound in her chest
her eyes begin filling up with water as
she remembers
daenerys says i was murdered by jon snow
the man i loved and who i thought loved
me
that's right says kinvara you and jon
snow were brought together for a reason
you were brought together to fight
against the great other but you allowed
yourself to be consumed by not only the
force you have while you're on the back
of your dragon
but the fear you have in your heart the
fear of losing what power you still have
i don't know what happened says daenerys
i mean
i remember what happened but i don't
know why
it felt like something evil was inside
me i never wanted things to end like
this
but it was as if i could not stop it
from happening as if
something was moving me in that
direction it felt like
something had its grip on me and would
not let go
the lord of light has brought you back
just as the lord of light brought back
jon snow
says kinvara you have been reborn in the
great flames overlore
his fire has clenched your soul daenerys
stormborn
now you must never lose sight again you
once said
you wanted to leave the world better
than you found it now you have another
opportunity to do that
neither of you know it yet but you and
jon snow still need each other
no he doesn't says daenerys if he needed
me he wouldn't have murdered me
the night king and his army of the dead
have been defeated
cersei lannister is dead the iron throne
is for the taking
i'm sure sansa stark got exactly what
she wanted
by naming jon snow the king kinvara says
well you are right about one thing
daenerys cersei lannister
and the night king are dead but you
haven't defeated all of our enemies
the great other still looms over
westeros threatening our very existence
what do you mean the great other says
daenerys with a slight grin on her face
kinvara says there is still so much you
don't know daenerys stormborn
did bran stark ever say who made the
night king
i don't believe he did says daenerys can
vara helps daenerys back on her feet
she walks her over to one of the burning
braziers
kenvara glares into the fire and she
says
like i was saying you may have defeated
the night king
in his army of the dead but they weren't
working alone
they have never worked alone daenerys
has a confused look on her face when she
says
melisandre never said this why wouldn't
she warn us about other threats
kinvara says melisandre was but one
small
instrument of the lord of light there
was only so much she could do
when melisandre lost her faith she lost
her ability to see everything that lies
ahead
the flames only gave her glimpses but we
can see
far more daenerys stormborn our faith
has never wavered
and the lord of light has rewarded us
for that kinvara looks deeper into the
flames burning in the brazier
she brings daenerys in closer then says
have a look for yourself
daenerys looks into the fire the
reflection of the flames is glowing red
in orange in their eyes kinvara says
do you see what i mean daenerys do you
see what lies ahead
this is why you and jon snow still need
each other
daenerys has a horrified look on her
face as she realizes what she is being
shown
daenerys says what do they want the same
thing they have wanted for thousands of
years says kinvara
all men must die the scene ends right
after kinvara says
this is why the new king of westeros has
all of us worried
in the following scene we are back in
winterfell sansa stark
the maester and several lords and ladies
of the north are all gathered below the
castle and it's crypt
the lowest level has been brought back
to life now that there are hundreds of
more candles lined up down here along
the walls
sansa stark and the maester are showing
the lords and ladies their recent
discovery
we hear sons of stark say we weren't
exactly sure what all of these drawings
were
maester walcan had sketches of these
images drawn and sent to the citadel
we're hoping they can help us figure out
what they are we are expecting a
response from them soon
we have also sent word to my brother
bran down in king's landing
he does have the ability to see things
others can't if anyone will be able to
shed some light on their significance
it will be him one of the northern lord
says just how big is this crypt your
grace
it seems like it goes on forever and
ever well
that's just a thing says sansa we don't
know
one of our guardsmen said he doesn't
know if there is an end
we sent a few more men ahead so we can
see where the underground passage leads
the northern lord says you sent a few
men down there
as he looks blindly into the darkness
that's only a hundred feet in front of
them
they must be braver men than i am your
grace i wouldn't want to find out what's
on the other end
i would have sealed this back up
immediately we may do that says sansa
but not until we find out how this got
here she holds her light up higher
illuminating the drawings on the wall
maester wolkan says
this drawing of the large werewood
surrounded by the grove of werewoods is
in the south
near harrenhal do any of you recognize
what these other images are
the northern lords and ladies study the
drawings for several minutes
examining them one by one this one your
grace
i think i know what this one is says the
northern lord
that looks like the children of the
forest your grace the drawing
of the beheading are you sure says sansa
why would the children of the forest
behead each other
sansa looks at maester wolkan and then
says are you familiar with this story
the maester shakes his head back and
forth know your grace
i am not there are legends of the
children of the forest
fighting with the giants and going to
war against the first men
but i don't recall ever hearing anything
about them killing one another
all records state that after they fought
the first men
their numbers were extremely low many
would say that's why they're no longer
around now
and others would even say they never
existed at all
i don't know why they would be fighting
each other but if they did
i suppose that wouldn't make them that
much different from us
your grace men have been fighting and
slaughtering each other for thousands of
years
sansa says i must speak with my brother
brian
he will know what to make of all this
the scene ends after the maester says
if these drawings are accurate your
grace i fear of learning what drove
these small creatures to such violence
in the next scene we are back on the
island of noth
there are roughly 100 men and women
gathered on the beach
under the light of the full moon during
the end of mesan day's burial ceremony
most of the men standing on the beach
are grey worms men who are all still
dressed in their unsolid uniforms
as is grey worm there are some island
natives that are attending
the ceremony as well as the men who
greeted greyworm on the beach the night
he arrived
everyone is standing in a circle
gathered around missandei's casket
while holding a white rose in their
hands the smell of salt water is thick
in the air
there is a man that has brown skin and
black hair
sitting next to the casket singing what
sounds like a very beautiful song
in a language we have never heard before
after the man finishes his song
the unknown man who has been helping
grey worm walks over to him and says
i am sorry for your loss i did not know
missandei of noth
but i am glad you brought her back home
she must have been someone very special
for you to bring her all the way here
from westeros
she was and still is says grey worm
i don't know what i will do now that she
is no longer here with me
i thought i would stay here with her for
the rest of our lives
but it will not be the same without her
i don't think the rest of your men want
to stay here
says the unknown man it wouldn't be very
safe for all of them either
unless they all want to squeeze into
that shelter with you
that won't be necessary says grey worm
right over his shoulder
we can see he brought about one dozen
ships with him from dany's fleet
the three-headed dragon can still be
seen on their banners and
sales the rest of greyworm's men are
still on the ships waiting and watching
as the ceremony nears its end well
where will you and your men go next says
the unknown man
grey worm looks out across the summer
sea and says
i don't know but we will be gone before
the sun rises
have you ever been to volantis says the
unknown man
it's not far from here it's right on the
other side of this sea
a few of our silk traders just arrived
this morning
i overheard them discussing something
they said they saw while leaving
volantis
now the man was drunk so i doubt he can
be believed
but i heard him say he saw the shadow of
what he thought was a dragon
flying over the city as they were
boarding their own ship
grey worm's eyes lock on his as he grabs
him by the arm
a dragon says grey worm are you sure
that's what he saw
the unknown man says no i can't be sure
because i wasn't there with him
but that's what i heard one of them say
the man was drunk
his words were slurred you know how men
are they swear their journeys are far
more dangerous than they actually are
i heard all of the dragons are dead i
doubt the man saw what he says he saw
greyworm lets go with the man's arm he
walks over to some of the other unsolid
men
who are standing on the beach greyworm
says drogon is across the sea in
volantis
get our men and our ships ready we will
be leaving
soon in the following scene we are
inside the library of the citadel
the archmaester ibros whoever saw
samwell studies while he was
there is sitting alone at a desk reading
a letter
we're not able to see who wrote the
letter or what it says
but it was sent from someone within the
red keep of king's landing
because it has the broken seal of the
three-eyed raven after the archmaester
finishes reading the letter
he rolls it back up then slides it
inside his sleeve
he stands up then walks across the
library to the other side
when he reaches the gate of the
restricted area he sticks his hand
inside of his other sleeve then removes
the key the archmaester unlocks the gate
walks inside then shuts it and locks it
behind him
the archmaester walks over to the
bookshelf that sits along the back wall
in the middle of the shelf there is a
book on werewolves
when he grabs this book it causes the
whole shelf to slide over
revealing there is a hidden room behind
it even the restricted area
has a restricted area when he steps
inside the hidden room
the bookshelf slides back behind him
there is only one shelf inside the
hidden room
as well as what looks like a metal lock
box that has more books inside
the archmaester opens up the book about
wherewoods then flips to the back
where another key is hidden he opens up
the lockbox
then removes the stack of books the
first book has an image on the front of
it
it looks like a member of the children
of the forest standing next to an
unknown man
right under that image it says the
origin of
but we can't see what it says after that
because the archmaester sets another
book down on top of it
on the front of the next book it reads a
detailed history of the lord commanders
at castle black
the next book the archmaester sits down
has an image of a weirwood grove on the
front of it
this one says the mysteries and legends
of the isle of faces
he sits down another book that just says
the birth of dragons
the next book says the works of brandon
the builder
it looks like there may be an image of
winterfell as well as the citadel on the
front of it
when archmaester ebros grabs the next
book he has to wipe the dust off of it
before he can read it himself
we don't get to see what this one says
but it must be what he was looking for
because he grabs the other stack of
books then locks them back inside the
small metal box
he stands back up while holding the book
he wants down at his side
he walks over to the wall then knocks on
it three times
this makes the bookshelf slide back open
again allowing him to leave the hidden
room
as we see him walk away the bookshelf
slams shut again
ending the scene in the next scene we
are following samwell
as he walks through the red keep he
walks across the old thorn room inside
the great hall
there is still a massive hole in the
side of the red keep where drogon had
blew out a hole in the side of the
building
there is what looks like over 100 ravens
walking around on the floor sitting on
different ledges
and flying in and out of the great hall
brain stark has definitely made himself
at home
sam walks out of the old throne room and
we keep following him
until he reaches the new chambers of the
hand of the king
he stops in front of the door then
knocks softly the door is opened up by
tyrion lannister
who says hello samwell how may i help
you
in a low voice sam says do you mind if
we speak inside
not at all says tyrion would you like a
drink no thank you says sam
as he walks in the room then shuts the
door behind him
before sam sits down he notices one of
the windows is open
he walks across the room then shuts it
as well
tyrion has a sly smile on his face when
he says
ah yes i see you are now a man of
secrecy samwell
now i know i am living in king's landing
again i suspect you must have something
good to say
otherwise you could have said it earlier
during the small council meeting
sam sits down next to him then says i do
kind of but i'm not sure good is the
word i would use for it
i'm a little concerned says sam have you
noticed
bran has been acting a little strange
lately
well stranger than usual no
i don't think i have says tyrion the boy
has seemed a little off since i first
met him
but that doesn't come as a big surprise
to me we've all been changed by what we
have been through over the years
i'm sure he's fine all things considered
besides
this is his first time living in king's
landing i'm sure he will adjust
i still remember when i first moved here
i hated it
but this city does have a certain charm
to it when it's not always consumed by
death destruction deceit and
backstabbing
actually now that i think of it king's
landing has no charm whatsoever
i still hate it here but we will have to
make do
this is our home now as it is king
brands what makes you say this samwell
did he say something to you well not
exactly says sam
it's not what he said it's what he did i
was looking through one of the old books
from the citadel
and i noticed something interesting i
was hoping bran could help explain what
it means
but when i handed him the book he threw
it into the fire
then he just sat there watching it burn
before he made brienne and i leave his
room
well that certainly doesn't sound like
something brain would do
says tyrion i have never seen him act
like that before
did he say anything else he did says
samwell
he said the book had no useful
information
we see another smile come across
tyrion's face before he says
oh i see well he might be right about
that
what do you mean says sam you and i both
know bran can see things that have
already happened
somewhere deep inside that mind of his
he has access to the entire history of
westeros
he must have thought the book was no
longer needed since you may already know
the answers you were looking for
well that's just a thing says sam he
never gave me any answers
it was like he didn't want me to know
that book wasn't mine
it belongs to the citadel we can't go
and destroy all of its written history
otherwise it will be lost forever if
something were to happen to bran
i understand your concern says tyrion
let me go speak with him
thank you says samwell he stands back up
then he heads for the door
when sam opens the door tyrion says now
before you go
i want to ask you something you said
there was something interesting you
discovered in the book
what was it in the final scene of this
episode we
go out beyond the wall jon ghost and the
wildlings are still moving through the
forest
as they search for the wherewit he saw
while he was sleeping
the moon is a crescent thin and sharp as
the blade of a knife
a murder of ravens are following them in
the sky
the sound of leaves are whispering in
the wind we're almost there
says the wilding woman who is still
riding on the back of john's horse
ghost is leading their pack he's been
sniffing at the ground
as he moves forward almost as if he's
following
someone or something sent go stop
suddenly
at the bottom of a steep stretch of
unbroken white snow
the direwolf looked back at jon sniffed
the air
then snarled we're here said the
wildling woman
about 80 yards in front of them was a
massive weirwood
sitting on the hill above the three at
raven's old cave
that's it says john that's what i saw in
my dream
when they reach the front of the
weirwood jon says we will set up camp
here for the night
have some of the men find wood for a
fire i want to go have a look around
inside the cave
the rest of the wildlings wait outside
while jon goes tormund
and the wildling woman go inside they
follow the roots of the weirwood
which look like dark white snakes
slithering in and out of the earth
around them
ghost is leading them once again as if
he knows where to go
as if he has been here before jon runs
his fingers along the roots of the
weirwood
when he looks at them his fingers are
blackened by the ash
he says someone must have lit a fire in
here it looks more like something
exploded in here says the wilding woman
there are thousands of bones all over
the ground
jon notices some of them don't look as
old as the rest
when the cave opens up in the center
they all stop when they see what looks
like a throne made of weirwood
ghost is still sniffing the ground
moving around some of the bones with his
nose
john sees the skull of a bear and the
skull of a wolf
there are dozens of human skulls and
near as many giant skulls that have been
crushed
all the rest were small and oddly shaped
they are the skulls of the children of
the forest
the roots had grown in and around and
through them
every one a few ravens are sitting atop
them
watching them enter the cave with their
bright black eyes that are full of
secrets
do you think the white walker stayed in
here says tormund
i don't know says john i don't think so
ghost begins rubbing himself against
john's leg
when he looks down at his direwolf he
notices he now has something in his
mouth
at first jon thought that it might have
been a bone but on the second look
he notices it has a metallic shine to it
he yanks it free from ghost
he studies it for a moment but then his
eyes go wide when he realizes what it is
the wildling woman says did he find
something what is it
i think this was my brother bran's says
john he holds it up by the light
so the others can see it has this sigil
of house stark on it
bran used to wear this around his neck
says john
this must be the same cave he mentioned
before bran was here
now ghost began snipping at jon's
fingers trying to get his attention
what is it boy says john what's wrong
ghost's eyes are glowing red john bends
down
as he is about to say something else but
then ghost starts forward
into the darkness that lies ahead we
should follow him
says the wildling woman the sound of
flapping wings can be heard
echoing off the cave walls they go
deeper
then deeper not knowing how far it goes
the scent of blood and smoke is still in
the air
do you hear that says john it sounds
like there is rushing water below us
i can hear too says tormund it sounds
like an underground river
they keep following the glowing red eyes
further and further down
until some flickering light can be seen
bouncing off the cave walls ahead
someone or something is down here with
them
i'm afraid of what we might find says
the wildling woman
whatever is down there is leading me
here says john
once again the cave opens up into a
larger chamber
there are candles burning down here
along the wall
there are also large mounds of melted
wax all over the ground
it looks as if there have been candles
burning down here for hundreds of years
even with their added light it's still
hard to see what's inside the chamber
it's not until they all walk into the
center when they can finally see what's
there
waiting for them in the shadows there
are three white werewood thrones flecked
with red
fashioned out of the living roots with
dead branches woven through them
they look exactly the same as the one
the three had raven set in
on the main floor of the cave the only
difference is there is something else
sitting on these werewood thrones
there are three small creatures all
staring at jon snow
they are three little wise men of the
children of the forest
who have nut brown skin dappled like a
deers with spots
in large ears they could hear things
that no man could hear
their eyes are big as well great golden
cat's eyes that could see in the dark
where a man's eyes only saw blackness
their hands only have three fingers and
a thumb
with sharp black claws instead of nails
there are ravens walking up and down
their little arms
ghost walks over by them then lays down
in front of their thrones
who are you said jon snow some men call
us the singers
while others call us the children of the
forest said the one sitting in the
middle
we are as you see us and now you will
understand why we could not come to you
except in a dream we have been watching
you
we have seen your birth and your
father's before you
we saw your first step and heard your
first word
and now you have arrived at last jon
snow though the hour is late
just as it was late for brandon stark my
brother says john so he was here
he was said the child of the forest and
that's why you are here now
we're afraid your brother is in grave
danger he needs you now more than ever
jon snow
i i don't understand says john what do
you mean he is in danger
how the night king and the army of the
dead are gone
why would he need me now did he ever say
how the night king was created
said the child of the forest you should
know jon snow
we showed you in your dream john sits
down
then inhales a deep breath as he shakes
his head
remembering what he saw when he leaned
his head against the werewolf
and shut his eyes he finally says
the children of the forest made the
night king the wildling woman
and tormund unsheathed their weapons and
stepped forward
wait says jon he gets back up
then stands in front of them before any
new bones get added to this cave
i want to hear what else they have to
say they brought me here for a reason
i want to find out why give us the full
story
why was the night king created why are
there bones all over this cave
why are you hiding out here beyond the
wall
why is my brother bran in danger
i'm sure you are familiar with some of
our story already
said one of the children of the forest
thousands of years ago
westeros belonged to us those you have
named the singers and the children of
the forest
this was our land this was our home
until your ancestors invaded it
when the first men arrived in westeros
thousands of your ancestors began to
settle in our lands
it wasn't long before they started
settling in more of our lands
further and further north until we had
to leave our own home
they began destroying everything that we
held sacred
all that was left for us was the deep
forest
the first men had brought with them new
gods horses
and even weapons of bronze that we could
not match
they were also bigger and stronger than
us threatening our very existence
we had warriors of our own who your
ancestors would name the wood dancers
but even with our secret arts of dark
magic we could only slow down the
advance of the first men
our greenseers and skin changers even
binded direwolves and
monstrous snow bears cave lions and
eagles
and serpents and more to their will but
the first men had us outnumbered
they slaughtered almost everyone we knew
we were on the brink of extinction
unfortunately
it drove us to act out of desperation we
felt like we had no choice
if we were to not only save our own kind
but our beautiful lands as well
that's when you made the night king said
jon snow
he sits back down the wildling woman and
tormund sheathed their weapons
and sit down as well we fought as
fiercely as the first men did to defend
our lives
yet it wasn't enough said the child of
the forest who was sitting in the middle
throne
one day we discovered there were some
first men
living among a few children of the
forest in the north the children who
came before me
did not like the idea of the first men
and the children of the forest laying
together
especially when we were at war with one
another
we captured and sacrificed one of these
first men
who would become the night king it was
this act that shifted the battle
back into our favor it wasn't long
before the first men gave up
and began fleeing from the north opening
our lands back
up this was all we wanted we wanted the
fighting to end
and we wanted the first men to stop
chopping down our sacred werewolves
the first men finally agreed the wisest
of your race
in ours met upon the god's eye and this
is where we negotiated
your ancestors would get the open lands
while ours would get the forest
the first men would stop cutting down
our werewolves while we would end the
night king's reign
but that never happened said john if you
ended the night king's reign
thousands of years ago then how did he
come back
we did end his reign said the children
of the forest the night king that you
saw us create in your dream
wasn't made of ice like the one you
fought this night king was only a man by
light of day
but the night was his to rule when we
agreed with the first man to end the war
we brought the night king down on his
knees before a heart tree in the north
where he was from a bronze sickle was
hooked around his throat
right before it was slashed i watched as
his feet drummed against the earth
afterwards his body was thrown into a
stone cell
deep beneath the ground this is when we
entered what you men
call the age of heroes this was when the
children of the forest
and the first men lived amongst each
other for many many years
but there was a new storm on the horizon
not all of our ancestors were happy
about our new living
arrangement with the first men the gods
gave us long lives
but not great numbers even in those days
we were few
yet in this new world the first men had
built there still wasn't room for us
this is what led to the war between the
children of the forest
you won't find this in your books of
written history
this is the story that's forgotten in
the north but the werewolves remember
some of us were willing to coexist with
the first men but there were others who
still wanted the first men dead
there were others who still wanted all
of our lands back
in the south there are children of the
forest who are roth
in the south there are children of the
forest who hate
and swear a bloody vengeance in the
south there are children of the forest
who fight
and kill they begin slaughtering and
sacrificing
any of us who would not stand beside
them this is what fractured the children
of the forest
as well as our secret arts of dark magic
this is when the long night
fell over westeros this is when the
night king returned
for our own survival we had to leave our
homes in the south
and flee here to the far north our race
has been split ever since
that winter lasted for an entire
generation
they nearly succeeded in that war but
with the aid of another man from the
north
we were able to push the white walkers
and the night king back
into the lands of always winter i think
i know this part of the story says jon
that's when you built the wall so you
could keep the night king and his army
in the north
under your watch did you see all of the
bones when you entered this cave jon
snow
the small ones are from members of our
own race when your brother bran was in
this cave
it was attacked by the night king and
the white walkers again
the night this cave was attacked they
killed the last of us living in the
north
now ask yourself this jon snow if the
night king is our enemy
just as he is yours then why would we
live north of the wall
where the night king and the army of the
dead were hunting
why would we choose to live on this side
of the wall with the night king
when he wants us dead because you felt
safer living beyond the wall
surrounded by the night king in his army
of the dead then you did in the south
among the rest of your own race says jon
very good now you know something jon
snow
says the child of the forest sitting on
the werewood throne in the center
when brain left the north we began
losing more
and more of our influence over his
abilities
now you know why bran is no longer the
same brother you once knew
he will only lose more of himself the
longer he is in the south
it's not only bran who is in danger now
all of westeros is
threatened i know you must have so many
questions jon snow
but you should leave soon as we said
when you first arrived
the hour is late you must go south while
you still
can john shakes his head in disbelief he
shuts his eyes
as he absorbs all this new information
i can't believe this is happening again
says john
i thought it was over i feel like i have
been living in a nightmare
i can't wake up from tormund giantsbane
throws his arm around jon's shoulder and
says
if you must go south again you know i
will ride with you
with his head in his hands john says
what should we do
how do we finally end this we thought
you might ask that
says the children of the forest we won't
be sending you out on your own
we have someone who will help you along
the way
john the wildling woman and tormund all
look at each other confused
who's going to help us says jon me
said a voice from the shadows in the
back of the chamber
the sound of boots scraping against the
bones on the ground startles ghost
the direwolf jumps up the glowing red
eyes dart back and forth as he looks
into the darkness
suddenly a man steps out from the shadow
and says
i will be coming with you jon snow who
are you says john
how long have you been hiding down here
in the dark i was a good friend of your
father's
my father says john the man says
you don't remember me jon snow but i was
there the day you were born
the man reaches out his hand so he can
shake john's
the episode ends right after the man
says my name
is helen reed
[Music]
you